PROFESSOR: In 6.042, we're
going to be pretty concerned
with proofs.
We're going to try
to help you learn
how to do rudimentary proofs
and not be afraid of them.
The most important
skill, in some ways,
is the ability to distinguish
a very plausible argument that
might not be totally right from
a proof which is totally right.
That's an important skill.
And it's a basic
understanding of what math is.
It's that distinction
between knowing
when a thing is
mathematically, absolutely
unarguable and inevitable
as opposed to something
that's just very likely.
It's interesting.
Physicists by and
large do a lot of math,
and they tend not to worry
so much about proofs.
But all the theoreticians
and the mathematicians
are in agreement
that you don't really
understand the
subject until you know
how to prove the basic facts.
Pragmatically, the
value of proofs
is that there's an awful lot
of content in this subject
and in many other
mathematical subjects.
And if your only way to figure
out what the exact details are
is memorization, you're
going to get lost.
Most of these rules and
theorems that we prove,
I can never remember
them exactly.
But I know how to prove them,
so I can debug them and get them
exactly right.
So let's begin by looking
at just examples of proofs
before we start to try to get
abstract about what they are.
And we'll look at
a famous theorem
that you've all seen from
early on in high school,
the Pythagorean theorem.
It says that if I have a right
triangle with sides a and b
and hypotenuse c, then there's
a relationship between a, b
and c-- namely that a
squared plus b squared
equals c squared.
Now, this is, as I said,
completely familiar.
But is it obvious?
Well, every once in a while,
students say it's obvious,
but what I think they really
mean is that it's familiar.
It's not obvious.
Part of the argument for the
fact that it's not obvious
is that for thousands
of years, people
have kept feeling
the need to prove it
in order to be sure that it's
true and explain why it's true.
There's a citation in the
notes of a website devoted
to collecting Pythagorean
theorem proofs.
There's over a hundred
of them, including
one by a former president
of the United States.
So let's look at one
of my favorite proofs
of the Pythagorean theorem.
And it goes this way.
There are four
triangles that are
all the same size, four
copies of this abc triangle,
which we've put in different
colors to distinguish them,
and a square, which for the
moment, is of unknown size.
And the proof of the
Pythagorean theorem
is going to consist of
taking these four shapes
and reassembling them so that
they form a c by c square
first, and then finding
a second arrangement
so that they form two squares--
an a by a square and a b
by b square.
Then by the theorem
of conservation
of paper or
conservation of area,
it has to be that
the c by c area is
the same as the a by
a plus b by b area.
And so a squared plus b
squared is equal to c squared.
Well, let's look at
those rearrangements.
And probably, you
should take a moment
to try it yourself before
I pop the solution up.
But there's the solution
to the first one.
It's the easier of the two.
This is the c by c arrangement.
The hint is that if
it's going to be c by c,
you don't have a
lot of choice except
to put the c [? long ?]
hypotenuses on the outside.
And then it's a matter of
just fiddling the triangles
around so they fit together.
And you discover there's
a square in the middle.
And that's just where that
extra square that is provided
will fit.
Also, this enables
you to figure out
what the dimensions
of the square are.
Because if you look at
it, this is a b side.
We're letting b be the longer of
the two sides of the triangle.
And this is the a
side, the shorter side
of another triangle.
So what's left here
has to be b minus a.
So now we know that
it's a b minus a
by b minus a square
from this arrangement.
And that's what
we've indicated here.
Now, the next arrangement
is the following.
We're going to take
two of the triangles
and form a rectangle,
another two triangles
to from a rectangle,
line them up in this way,
and fit the b minus a by
b minus a square there.
Now, where are the two squares?
Well, I didn't say that
the a by a and a and b by b
square needed to be separate.
In fact, they're not.
They're attached.
But where are they?
Well, let's look at this line.
How long is it?
Well, it's a plus
b minus a long,
which means that it's b long.
And suddenly, there is
a b and there's a b,
and I've got a b by b
rectangle right there.
But wait a second.
Here's a b minus a, and it's
lined up against a b side.
So if I look at what's left,
it's b minus b minus a.
It tells me that that
little piece is a.
And so sure enough, when
I add this hidden line--
conceptual line to
separate the two squares,
this part's a by a,
and that part's b by b.
And we've proved the
Pythagorean theorem.
So what about this process?
It's really very elegant,
and it's absolutely correct.
And I hope it's
kind of convincing.
And so this is a wonderful
case of a proof by picture
that really works in this case.
But unfortunately, proofs by
pictures worry mathematicians,
and they're illegitimately
worrisome because there's
lots of hidden assumptions.
An exercise that
you can go through
is to go back and
think about all
of the geometric
information that's
kind of being taken for
granted in this picture.
Like over here, how
did we know that that
was a right angle, that
this thing was a rectangle?
We needed that to be a right
angle because we were claiming
that this was a square.
Well, how did we know
that that was a rectangle?
Well, the answers are obvious.
We're using the fact that
the complementary angles
of a right triangle
sum to 90 degrees
because the angles of a triangle
in general sum to 180 degrees.
We're using that in a
bunch of other places.
We're also using the fact that
this is a straight line, which
may or may not be obvious.
But it's true, and
that's why it's
safe to add those distances
to figure out what it was.
My point is that
there are really
a whole lot of hidden
assumptions in the diagram
that it's easy to
overlook and be fooled by.
So let me show you an example
of getting fooled by a proof
by diagram.
And here is how to
get infinitely rich.
Let's imagine that I have a
10 by 11 piece of gold foil.
Actually, they could
be slabs of gold,
but let's think of this as
a rectangular shape that's
made out of gold.
And it's going to be rectangles.
Those are right angles there.
And what I'm going to do
is mark off the corners.
I'm going to mark off
a length down of 1,
and then I'm going to
mark off a length of 1
and shift it so that it
touches the diagonal,
and do the same thing
in this lower corner.
And now, let's just shift
these shapes, the top one going
southwest and the second
one going northeast.
And what I wind up
with is this picture so
that I've now got those little
red triangles protruding
above the shape.
OK, cool.
Well, what do we know?
This is now side 10 because I've
subtracted 1 from its length
here .
And this is side 11
because that used to be 10,
and I've added 1 to
its length there.
So that's cool because
now, what I can do
is take those protruding
triangles out,
and they'll form a
little 1 by 1 square.
And suddenly, I have this
little bit of gold that's extra.
But look what's here.
It's a 10 by 11 rectangular
shape of gold foil again.
So I just rotate
this by 90 degrees,
and I start all over again.
I can keep generating
these little 1
by 1 shapes of
gold foil forever.
I could get infinitely rich.
OK, well there's
something wrong with that.
It's violating all kinds
of conservation principles,
not to mention that it would
undermine the price of gold.
So what's the bug?
Well, you probably
can spot this,
but maybe you've been fooled.
What's going on is there's
an implicit assumption
that those little triangles that
I cut off were right triangles
and that this line that I
claimed was of length 11
was a straight
line, and it's not.
Those triangles have two
sides that are of length 1.
They're isosceles
triangles, but they're
lying up against a diagonal
that's not 45 degrees.
And so they're not
right triangles.
And that line isn't straight.
And 10 and 11 were
close enough that it
wasn't visually obvious.
So this is a way to
simply put one over
on you with a proof by picture.
And if I had been
asked to justify
how do I know it's
a straight line,
that bug would have emerged.
But you're not likely to notice
that if it isn't visually
obvious, which is why we worry
about that some of these proofs
[? by picture. ?]